[Musique]
quand on aura mis ça au point ce bar à
10,6 standford moorhouse spelman à
[Musique]
quelque chose cannes stein a passé toute
sa vie à essayer de pertes
on a prouvé que faire un voyage dans le
passé c'était possible il faut seulement
travailler dessus encore quelques temps
ça me fout la trouille mais tu
m'inspires toi tu vas aller loin c'est
sûr et comme papa est plus là c'est un
mois t'aider à y arriver si tu as besoin
que tu joues au grand frère tout le
temps eh ben je suis le seul grand frère
que tu es
[Applaudissements]
police de new york ne bougeait plus
[Musique]
calvin walker un adolescent noir de 19
ans aurait été tué par balle par un
agent de la police de new york
walker avait pour seul et unique arme
son téléphone cellulaire
je suis tellement désolé de tout ce qui
est arrivé si je pouvais remonter le
temps j'ai rangerait tout ça on retourne
dans le passé on le sort de là il est
sauvé l'inra qu'un nombre limité de fois
pour le faire donc il faut que tout soit
absolument parfait quel jour on est
aujourd'hui on est le 28 juin
[Musique]
sebastian il faut que ça marche il
s'agit de contrôler un truc sur lequel
on n'a aucun contrôle
mon frère méritait pas ce qui lui est
arrivé il manque combien de fois tu es
allé dans le passé si on n'est pas des
super héros
où est passée la justice on peut pas
refaire ça nous reste seulement deux
sauts dans le passé
où est la justice pour nos fils pour
monfils
corps tout ça va-t-il s'arrêter dans
tout notre pays il faut que tu nous
écoutes tu vas te faire descendre à
nantua par terre